I'm Jerry Schumacher and 18 years old
I'm from Chattanooga Tennessee I am
creating a safer and healthier world for
parents and newborns my friend's son
died before his eight month birthday
they didn't know the cause at the time
but have found out that it's SIDS sudden
infant death syndrome that's when I
really ventured into this idea of an
alert system that will update parents
tracking vital signs in babies I'm very
prepared to venture into this field
because I did eight years of science
research and worked alongside nanotech
researchers to create a product that I
was really proud of and I really got
into the idea of being an entrepreneur
venturing into an area where I could
really mold something and make something
and change something